(e(en ukrainien)
"L"Les forces séparatistes nous
onont dit d'évacuer immédiatemet
paparce que l'Ukraine préparent
unune agression majeure, dit
TaTatiana, et on entend les tirs
dedepuis deux jours. La Russie
leleur promis un toit et un peu
d'd'argent dès leur arrivée.
M Mais ce matin, c'est le chao.
ToTout l'or du monde ne pourrait
coconsoler Valentina qui font à
lalarmes quand on lui demande ùu
esest son mari.
- - He stays over there?
- - Yes!
- - C'est la situation de beaucp
dede femmes ici. Les maris ont é
apappelés à la mobilisation
gégénérale. Donc, s'il y a une
guguerre, bien, c'est pour se
babattre. Donc, il y a beaucoup
d'd'anxiété chez les femmes,
évévidemment.
PlPlus les jours passent, plus
c'c'est impossible de se détachr
dede l'atmosphère militaire qui
rrègne ici. Et pendant que la
cocommunauté internationale
reregarde, attend, nerveuse, eh
bibien, en Ukraine, le
gogouvernement a décidé qu'il
fafallait maintenant se préparer
auau pire.
SeSe préparer au pire reste ce n
àà témoigner Tamara Alteresco
dadans ce reportage depuis
plplusieurs semaines. Vous la
susuivez depuis quatre ans mais
T Tamara Alteresco,
cocorrespondante à Moscou pour
RaRadio-Canada, Bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Tamara, vous êtes déployée à
MoMoscou depuis septembre 2018.
CoCommenter ces images parce que
c'c'était la préparation de la
guguerre. Vous avez découvert tt
çaça sur la route avec les char
d'd'assaut.
- On a commencé à comprendre et
avavec l'équipe de Moscou, que
c'c'est sérieux. Ils aidèrent àa
frfrontière de l'Ukraine et autr
dudu 16 février, Joe Biden a dit
quque l'attaque était imminente.
IlIl y avait toujours ces images
sasatellites ou envoyaient des
chchars. On ne savait pas où ils
ététaient. Monsieur GI dit que e
n'n'est pas sérieux. On est allà
BeBelgorod, on a roulé des heurs
etet des heures en compagnie
jujusqu'à ce qu'un villageois ns
didise voulait l'avoir?
SuSuivait-moi.
OnOn est tombé sur une colonne i
fafaisait des centaines de mètr.
C'C'est la premier foie que j'ai
vuvu le fameux Z qui était sur n
dedes blindés. Et c'est là... oa
cocomprit l'emploi de la menace
mamais aussi on l'a incarné. C't
unune chose de voir les images
sasatellites, d'entendre les
didiscours politiques d'un côté
cocomme de l'autre mais de voixt
de p parler aux résidents de ce
ququ'il vivait en temps réel.
- - Ils avaient peur résidents?
- - Il n'y croyait pas. Une dame
didisait qu'on a appelé la
ninitration passionna stationner
dedes char d'assaut devant chez
momoi devant mon commerce.
OnOn lui a dit que c'est dans ls
asassises militaires. On n'avait
papas le droit de les filmer. On
leles affirmait en cassette. Le
mymystère qui plane autour de
acactivités. Et plus les jours
papassaient, plus c'était
didifficile de les retrouver. On
leles retrouvait surur les routs
dedevant la gare.
- - C'est impressionnant parce e
j'j'imagine que tout ça été fait
enen secret et de les avoir
dédécouvert ils nous ont pas
imimportuné ils ont laissé fair.
- - Il n'y avait plus de secret.
IlIl y a eu des camions-citernes
etet on a parlé de ravitaillemet
onon a vu aussi des camions
trtransportés l'équipement
nénécessaire pour établir des
hhôpitaux de fortune.
CÇa devenait très vrai.
QuQuand Poutine a reconnu
l'l'autonomie des territoires du
LoLouhansk de Donetsk on a comps
ququ'il allait avoir une invasin
ouou une incursion, moi je la
vovoyais arrêtée à Marioupol, ce
ququi était encore humain
ininimaginable. Et le soir du 24
VlVladimir Poutine a fait son
didiscours, c'était en avec vous
etet puis avec Marie-Ève Bédard,
onon est H&M et on attendait les
prpremiers frappes. Stress
sysymbolique. Il y a eu un avant
etet un après.
- - Vous êtes habitué sur le
teterrain vous avez vécu plusies
momoments ce fort.
OnOn va en vivre avec vous. Vous
ététiez sur le front.
SuSuite le déchirement de cette
guguerre, des peuples frères. Ue
pepersonne en Russie, l'autre en
UkUkraine. On vous écoute dans n
cocourt extrait de ce reportage.
- - On voit des chars circuler,
dedes convois de soldats. Et les
gegens attendent pour rentrer àa
mamaison. Et on vient de parlerà
VaValia qui nous a dit que sa
sosoeur... et c'est ça qui vous
exexplique l'absurdité de cette
ininvasion. Valia habite du côté
rurusse, à 7 km de la frontière.
ElElle attend pour rentrer chez
elelle. Sa soeur habite à Khark.
ElElles se parlent au téléphone
auaujourd'hui. Sa soeur est cace
dadans le sous-sol parce qu'il a
dedes bombardements. Elle est
ininquiète. Elle est terrorisée.
ElElle entend ces bombardements
paparce qu'on est à seulement
5050 km de cette ville qui est
bobombardée. Et c'est la réalité
dede ces villes frontalières.
QuQuand on dit qu'on mène la
guguerre aux ukrainiens, il y a
bebeaucoup de douleurs ici. C'et
dedes familles, c'est des cousis
ququi habitent de l'autre côté.
MaMadame à sa soeur juste à côt,
etet elle sait que l'armée russe
ququi a accaparé son secteur,
soson village est en train de
bobombarder la ville de sa soeu.
- - Que ça fait de vie c'est ime
lala?
- - La guerre est toujours
ababsurde, c'est lent et c'est
dédésolant. Étant donné l'histoe
dede la Russie et l'histoire de
l'l'Ukraine, la majorité des
RuRusses que je connais ont des
raracines ukrainiennes.
C'C'est un exemple et ça, à
BeBelgorod, c'est exactement lùu
onon était trois semaines plus
ttôt. Voyez les charges déployer
etet c'est devenu un centre
d'd'opérations importants.
- - Nous on tire des missiles
auaussi. Sur Kharkiv notamment.
- - Surtout. J'ai été en danger
phphysique. Si je parlais avec
MaMarie-Eve on s'écrivait, elle
elelle vivait un danger réel por
soson intégrité personnelle,
nonon c'était plus le silence. n
vava en parler, la répression et
lala censure. Détaillé d'informr
mamais avec le menace.
- - Est-ce que les gens vous
lalaisseront une certaine
ininquiétude ou fierté?
- - Les : j'avais la flemme,
imimpression pour avoir fait du
teterrain, il n'y a pas eu
bebeaucoup de soutien pour cette
guguerre. Savoir qu'il y a une
totolérance pour une incursion
vevers le Donbass, parce que la
CrCrimée des puissants coups de
fefeu Vladimir Poutine. Il y avt
cecette illusion généreuse qu'on
popourrait en faire autant avec
leles territoires de Donetsk
LoLouhansk.
- - Quand vous avez quitté Moscu
onon a parlé de cette loi
rérépressive à l'endroit des
jojournalistes conduise qu'à se
cocontrer au message Ukraine, vs
avavez fait un reportage qui
ilillustrer les entraves à votre
mémétier. On écoute un reportage
(s(slogans)
- - Les gens sortent manifester,
mamais c'est complètement
ininterdit. Les gens sont arrêts
sosous nos yeux, montés dans
dedes autobus. Ça fait partie
d'd'un environnement de sanction
ququi est à son comble.
N Notre équipe a même été chase
dedes lieux. Impossible de film;
etet ce, y compris les médias qi
didiffusent ce qui est jugé de
lala désinformation par
lele Kremlin, s'expose maintenat
àà une peine qui peut maintenant
alaller jusqu'à 15 ans de priso.
- - Les Russes subissent cette
rérépression et vous comme
jojournaliste aussi vous subissz
dedes pressions, jamais vu, jams
vévécu depuis que vous étiez en
RuRussie?
- - . Absolument j'ai couvert.
BeBeaucoup de défilé pro naval
lilien et des défilés contre
popoutine, jamais on s'en est ps
àà la presse. On s'en prend... a
ararrive qu'on tape sur la prese
MeMesames interdit d'être là por
cocouvrir l'événement. C'est la
prpremière fois qu'on m'a dit :
OuOust,
- - dégage.
- - Dégage, et cette épée au-
dedessus de nos d'une possible
ararrestation, et une peine
d'd'emprisonnement. Ça été
coconcrétisé le lendemain. Et ds
cecette manifestation, il y avat
dedes gens probablement payés, i
nonous suivait. Sa voix qu'on et
auau téléphone, on nous arrachat
leles téléphones et s'imposer
phphysiquement devant nous. On
prprend des mesures
exextraordinaires pour empêcher
leles journaliers de fait le
trtravail. Pas seulement les
jojournalistes étrangers mais
auaussi les journalistes
inindépendants.
- - Avez-vous l'impression que a
jojournaliste étranger courait
plplus de risques que les
jojournalistes indépendants qui
ététaient enfermés?
- - C'est toujours du journalise
ététranger passe en effet par ls
RuRusses. Ça été très clair pare
quque le lendemain après
l'l'adoption de la loi, qui
memenaçaient de 15 ans de prison
etet que ça concernait autant ls
mémédias étrangers que les médis
lolocaux, il fallait prendre une
dédécision : Anne-Marie, est-ce
ququ'on peut continuer à faire
nonotre travail en Russie avec s
nonormes et les standards que ns
avavons, comme média indépendan.
DeDes gens qui nous écrivent nos
dedemander si on est un média
inindépendant, on l'est.
PePendant quatre ans, les gens
sosont étonnés quand je leur di,
fafais mon travail avec une grae
liliberté.
- - Vous avez écrit un papier au
momoment de votre départ. Rassuz
vovotre enfant et vous parliez u
prprivilège de l'homme que vous
avaviez d'aller dans ces pays vs
dédécriviez Moscou comment une
viville qui ne doit pas.
IlIl y avait beaucoup de joie de
vivivre.
- - Une grande capitale
eueuropéenne.
- - On apprenait aujourd'hui qun
apappelait des entreprises
frfrançaises acquittées des
mimilliers d'emplois... avez-vos
l'l'impression que ces sanctions
ququ'on impose va affecter la ve
dede ces gens que vous avez
cocouverts et côtoyés. Que vont-
ilils ressentir?
- - À ce moment il y a un
momouvement de panique. Je parlà
dedes amis. Il manque de sucre,
DoDoors, de produits sanitairest
dede produits dont on ne manque
papas en les gens achètent
papanique.
CeCela fait beaucoup et quand on
vava acheter un café, on enlève
leles cachet. Ont fait des achas
papapa. À part les McDo et les
chchaînes américaines au que la
jejeunesse qui n'a jamais rien
coconnu que le luxe qui vient de
l'l'étranger..
- - à l'occidentale.
- - À l'occidentale. À part ça l
y y a eu des primes. Les
coconséquences, le rouble. Des
mamarchés se précipitent et c'et
cece qui s'en vient qui fait
plpleurer c'est l'isolement de a
RuRussie.
- - J'ai dit en ouverture que vs
ététiez sorti temporairement.
J'J'imagine que votre rêve d'y
reretourner?
- - Oui, on a un bureau à Moscou
j'j'ai mon appartement, ma filla
papassé la moitié de sa vie à
MoMoscou. On s'est attaché à cee
vivie. C'est juste un départ...
- - précipitez quand même.
- - Oui on était pas obligé de
didire qu'on suspendait nos
acactivités. Nos bureaux sont
totoujours là. On repartira quad
lala tension va redescendre et
ququ'on pour assurer la sécurité
dede nos employés.
- - On espère que tout se passe
bibien et que vous retourniez le
plplus rapidement possib